bonjour eric zemmour bonjour la crise
que nous sommes en train de vivre
est-ce que selon vous c'est un tournant
dans le quinquennat
un petit peu comme celui qu'on avait pu
vivre en 82 83 avec ce qu'on avait
appelé le tournant de la rigueur
pour françois mitterrand on peut dire
effectivement que ces 83 après 82
effectivement vous avez raison on est là
alors là à l'époque au dg les jaunes il
avait déjà dit qu'ils renonçaient à
respecter les 3%
vous savez la fameuse règle de
contraintes budgétaires dans maastricht
qui l'avait promis au contraire d'
appliquer strictement et là maintenant
on voit qu'on est passé dans une toute
autre
un autre ordre de grandeur là on la
crise économique a été si terrible que
mon bazar de toutes limites et que vous
avez vu que même les autorités
européennes sont contraintes de renoncer
à tout ce qui a fait les règles mascré
chienne depuis depuis 30 ans là on voit
la bce qui qui qui qui team qui met à
disposition des états européens 750
milliards et même qui est prête à aller
au delà c'est à dire qu'il faut bien
comprendre ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'il n'ya plus de contraintes de
la dette puisque tous les pays européens
peuvent faire n'importe quelle dette la
banque centrale rama cela les dettes et
donc créer de l'argent pour compenser
les dettes on se rend pas bien compte
encore de ce que ça veut dire mais ça
veut dire que maastricht est mort et que
toutes les contraintes européennes sont
finis on y renonce
alors ça peut si tous les pays sont
d'accord
bon c'est ça ça très bien même s'il y
aura peut-être des conséquences et
durera peut-être le retour de
l'inflation j'en sais rien avec on est
dans une telle crise économique que je
vois pas pour l'instant le retour
d'inflation voyez on est on est
tellement bas que bon mais en revanche
il va y avoir des conflits au sein des
pays européens déjà les pays comme
l'allemagne et surtout la hollande
glauque riches refusent cet abandon des
contraintes alors que les pays du sud en
réclame toujours plus il y à là de quoi
détruire complètement et la zone euro et
l'europe
d'ailleurs jacques delors
cette sortie de son silence de vie de
vieil homme puisqu'il à 94 ans pour pour
dire que effectivement l'europe et et
pourrait en mourir
d'autant plus que la solidarité entre
les pays n'avaient pas brillé par sa
part son évidence en dire il ya toujours
un problème avec les gens qui sont
partisans de l'union européenne que je
comprends je comprends le rêve européen
je comprends les arguments du nombre etc
je n'ai jamais été étranger à ce genre
d'arguments mais ce qu'ils ne voient pas
c'est que les institutions de l'europe
l'europe ont depuis 30 ans une idéologie
qui est l'idéologie justement de du
libéralisme et du mondialisme et du
refus de la souveraineté du principe
même de la souveraineté du principe même
des frontières du principe même d'un
d'état puisque justement ils veulent que
ce soit le consommateur qui soit le
maître absolu de tout les élégances et
que écoeuré que les cullen et que le
marché et que le droit doivent régner et
c'est ça que ne comprennent pas les gens
comme comme émana chrome c'est très
classique chez les français il projette
le le le la france c'est à dire l'état
nation française sur un état-nation
européens sauf que les autres et en
particulier les légendes bruxelles n'ont
pas cette ce rêve là et non pas cette
idéologie là et c'est l'éternel
quiproquos si j'ose dire entre les
partisans de l'europe en france et les
partisans de l'europe
ailleurs les partisans de l'europe en
france veulent la france en grand et les
autres ne veulent pas la france en grand
ils veulent ils veulent le monde en
petit et c'est ça fait des années que ça
dure et hors l'ailé les français au nom
de l'europe des armes l'état français et
on le voit bien
on le voit bien là puisqu'on n'a aucune
âme on s'est complètement déshabillés on
a renoncé à anneaux à nos stocks de
masques on a renoncé notre industrie
sanitaires etc et de l'autre on a des
français qui disent oui mais l'europe va
remplacer mais l'europe ne remplace
jamais parce que les autres ne veulent
pas qu'elle remplace comprenez ils n'ont
pas la même
vision de l'europe et je vous dis c'est
un quiproquo qui dure depuis 30 ans et
qui est qui conduit à la catastrophe
aujourd'hui merci eric zemmour